hey guys and welcome to another
moneymaking video today is going to be
another free-to-play video in somewhat
of a continuation of one of my pay
toplay moneymaking methods uh and this
is going to be combining armor sets but
in freeo playay now there are a couple
sets that worked quite well for me uh
mainly in this uh episode I'm going to
go over the uh Green Dragon hide set as
well as some of the Rune armor sets or
the god run IR armor sets um which in
total uh profited me about 700k and that
most of these offers were just left in
overnight not very much attention needed
uh just time so hope you guys enjoy and
let's get started all right guys so to
address a few things before we get
started um I do realize having 5 mil on
the freet toplay count isn't totally
realistic you might as well buy a bond
but it's just to help illustrate my
point more also I am technically on a
PID Play Count now to do a lot of these
methods you will need four offer slots
not all the time uh but this is just a
simpler way of doing it I'll be on a
free topl world and only be using freeo
playay items and uh how you could get
around this is just by having two
accounts and just split the money
between the two it's a little more
annoying I do realize that but just
having all everything focused on one
screen is going to be easier for you
guys to understand than me flipping back
and forth between two screens so that's
why I'm on a pay to playay account
account and I hope you understand so to
start off we have a g Tracker open here
um and I've gone and turned my account
to a free to-play only account mode
there's a little toggle in the account
settings and uh we're just looking
through all these here so these are all
item sets uh and crafting so anything
that can combine or be crafted is under
listed under here uh one I found
interesting is the green dragon hide as
you can see it says a 7K margin we'll
have to see about that because that'll
be ex extremely good and of course this
item trades a lot and I want to quickly
look at the actual item itself cuz I
know the green di body chaps and vs we
I'll buy really quickly now for selling
not as big a quantity but
still still five or 600 a day that
should be easily doable overnight so
what we're going to do is first off buy
a green Dragonite
set so it's saying 14k which would be
pretty amazing and we're buying for 17K
okay and let's sell that back as
well so actually want a really good
margin to flip that but yeah we'll go
ahead and now we're going to go ahead
and buy the individual pieces now the
bind Lim is 70 and uh well we'll just
price check every single one of these I
know it's a bit of a pain in the ass to
do all this but it'll be worth it di
chaps and green deide
vs uh by the them all and then we're
going to Zell them back instantly right
away and that all we going to need all
the information you're going to need at
least for this first
flip I guess you could call it a flip or
moneymaking method whatever you want
anyway let's go to the history here so
now we all we have to do is basically
just calculate what we're expecting to
get for the margin so
17K we might be able to sell four we'll
have to see about that and take off the
uh price we sold all these parts at
because that's what we're going to try
to buy the individual pieces for so
4455 minus
2182 -
1348 saying a 9k margin which be pretty
crazy but we'll give it a try so we'll
go ahead and buy 70 of each
piece and not terribly
expensive green
dehy well we'll click on it in history
here and the body 4455 do s of those as
well and last up is
the green deide
chaps which we'll do for one more and
buy 70 so uh we'll come back when these
have all bought and uh show you how it
works all right so that probably took an
hour and a half or something to buy all
those not too lengthy and we did manage
to buy the entire sets worth of the
green deide uh so we'll go ahead and
collect collect it all costs us
about just under 600k so honestly not
that much so now the easiest part you're
going to do is just go to sets find the
one you're looking for so green dragon
hiide click it once and Bam there we go
70 Green Dragon hiide sets now we're
going to recheck the price here again
green dehy
set still looks to be ridiculously high
now we're probably going to have to sell
these overnight because wow 17K still
I just can't imagine those actually
selling for that much but cuz they're
regularly at
8K I think we're going to take a more
realistic approach here and go for
maybe
[Music]
14499 yeah for we'll do the actively
trade PR no that's good okay selling
them for about one z uh 1 mil and 14k
and yeah so this is going to take a
while to sell if we look at the Green
Dragon sets and while they do sell about
600 a day they tend to be in big spikes
like this 131 sold there but they will
trickle through hopefully and we can see
over the last 24 hours uh the item does
Spike a lot in value occasionally so
this could be sustainable even in the
future anyway we will let these sit for
a while and come back when they have
fully sold all right what a pleasant
surprise to wake up to we have all of
the green dragon ads have sold for
14499 not sure how long it took because
I did leave this in overnight but that
is going to leave us with a
437k profit off of that item pretty nice
considering we only paid 600k for the
item in total um so really good margin
on that I wouldn't expect to get a good
that type of margin but still you could
expect to get 100 200k even leaving that
in overnight uh which is pretty good
also what I like about this is it does
only use three offer slots so you can do
this on one account which does save a
little bit of time so we're going to do
one more example of the item set and
crafting for free to play for you guys
the next thing I'm going to be looking
at is the sidom and Armor Set uh G
tracker is showing a 28k mergin here
we'll go ahead and check it in game oh
my God I have so many tabs
open so we'll have to remember we at
about 437k in profit so we'll remember
that after and see how much we actually
total profit in total uh so first I did
find a little easier way to do this so
first off bu the San set so the LG is
one we're looking
for so we insta bought it for 212 now
instead of selling it back and buying
all the individual pieces and selling
them just unpack it just realize this
while I was doing it last time unpack
and now sell back all the pieces so
you're kind of just doing the process in
Reverse
essentially sell off all the pieces
[Music]
now and just hit collect and that's it a
little bit quicker thought you guys
might appreciate that so now we're going
to do another calculation similar to the
last one just get our calculator open
here so we are going to be hopefully
selling the items for 212 once we
combine
them um take off the sodomin full home
the serid plate
body the serin plate
legs and the S kite Shield 53 660 is
going to leave us with about a 30k
profit on each one that is pretty nice
and um we could probably
afford 30 or 40 of these uh we'll have
to check let's just see how many we
could expect to actually buy of these
open up the full Al just to have a quick
look again we're going to leave this in
not overnight but I mean for a
while and seran full Helm 10 and four
and about 143 a day so that's not too
bad and um let's just check another item
quick
and one and nine how many per
day price and about 100 so I think
that's still reasonable we could
probably buy 30 or 40 in maybe a couple
hours hopefully so let's go ahead and
put an offering for all of the pieces
here now that's going to be a little
tricky since okay so it's going to cost
roughly 175
each um so 175k each
uh we'll do 30 we should be good with
30 hopefully if I did my math correctly
so 30 seram full Helms sidom plate
bodies 30 of
these sidam and plate
legs 30 of these as well and hopefully
we didn't this up and 30 of
these all right we went back and
just reduced all the offers to 25 there
we go uh we have 867k left over but
that's fine and uh we'll leave this in
for a while and come back when they have
bought all right so I'm getting a
suspicion that the bind limit on this is
actually eight I'm not really sure
what's tipping me off but um well we
have eight of each thing and that seems
a little suspicious I'm joking the BM is
most definitely eight so we'll collect
everything and uh we do have eight of
everything and we'll pull the rest of
the offers
out and just like last time we're going
to be combining these into a
set come down here to set look for it on
here where
yet sometimes if you have um some of it
noted and others not becomes kind of an
issue come on where is the S set on here
must be there we go perfect sadom set LG
and now we're going to be selling it
back for hopefully we can even price
check with another one
we're going to waste the money to price
check it here whatever 215 is what we're
going to sell them all back
for 215 on the dot it seems to be what
did we buy it for before 212 that's okay
actually actually more of course that's
okay uh so $
24999 and that will be it so we'll come
back when they have sold and calculate
our final profit for the day all right
the sopin sets have fully sold all nine
of them for 250 15K each not bad and
let's claim the money and see what we're
ending today at 5671 K we made close to
700k in profit in free to play and um on
that last flip how much we get it would
have been a lot more except for the
limit was much higher so it's 5437 that
we were at um from the first flip so 56
71- 5437 we got about 234k on the second
part of that flip uh but yeah so you can
really see that combining items even in
free to play can be extremely profitable
honestly I just look over that g tracker
list um couple times a day um if you
don't have G tracker or you don't have
the pro membership to G tracker just
look up armor sets armor sets um dragon
head sets there's not actually a lot of
freeo playay items that can be combined
but every single piece of armor can and
uh it's pretty easy to check the margin
like I did in the video all right guys I
hope you enjoyed and I will see you guys
in the next video
oh
[Music]